recorded to this computer and we're on. Hello everybody, it's Dr. Cutters. This is
the 12th of December. You're ready for Christmas and going to go through some questions
on today's Zoom call that people have sent in that have emailed in. So let's just jump right
to that so we can open it up for questions. One question was, I'm contemplating going for an
IV drip of vitamin C. I'll continue using the right machine. Please advise your thoughts on this.
So remember on what we've spoken about with IV vitamin C and chemotherapy. So if you are doing
the chemotherapy you may want to inquire about using IV vitamin C with chemotherapy to your ecologist.
However, remember what I've spoken about with this in the past IV vitamin C. So vitamin C
in very high doses actually acts as an oxidant. That's the current belief right now. So vitamin C in
normal doses, thousand milligrams of vitamin C is an antioxidant. Therefore a college is typically
do not want you to use vitamin C while you're doing chemotherapy because chemotherapy is an oxidizing
agent. And if you're using antioxidant agents while you're using an antioxidant agent to kill cancer
that it's a little contraindicative. However, high dose vitamin C, the current belief is that it's
actually acting as an oxidizing agent. So I don't think there's a conflict of interest in doing
high dose IV vitamin C while doing chemotherapy but you do you may want to consult with your
oncologist. If you are not doing chemotherapy then by all means you could do IV vitamin C
and that actually acts like a chemotherapy and it certainly doesn't impede anything with the
right machine or anything else you're doing. So I'm a big fan of vitamin C IV so go ahead and do it
in my book. Other questions ever since chemotherapy I have had a salty taste in my mouth. Can you
recommend your comment on what might be the cause. So remember your taste buds taste certain
flavors right bitter sour salty and sweet these are your taste buds are simply receptors on
your on the on your tongue. So if you have damage to those receptors they're not going to you're
not going to have that taste. So the most common cause of loss of taste or loss of certain
tastes which would accentuate other tastes following chemotherapy is the chemotherapy's damage to
the receptors. The taste buds themselves so chemotherapy can damage your taste buds so it's
very common where people will say oh my gosh after I did chemotherapy I can't taste a thing anymore
or after I did chemotherapy I only everything tastes bitter to me or everything tastes sour to me or
everything tastes sweet to me or everything tastes salty to me and that is because if the other
receptors were damaged and the salty ones were things they're going to taste much more salty to you.
Unfortunately there's not a whole lot one can do to that except stimulate those receptors so
from a neurological functional neurological perspective a person could so you can take this picture
right here or Google one yourself and you can take a sour substance and put like drops of lemon juice
on this part of your tongue here to stimulate those receptors. So from a functional neurology
perspective the more you stimulate a nerve the more you stimulate a receptor the more that receptor
is going to turn on and fire back neuron. So if you can put something bitter here something sweet here
something sour on the edges here you can stimulate those receptors and hopefully gain those taste
spots back so not everything tastes salty. So that's one thing from a functional neurology perspective
you can do the other thing you can do is to help detox the chemotherapy and that is doing the foot
baths doing liver cleanses doing making sure you're doing your coffee animals do castor opax on
where the liver do everything you can to get out that toxin so that you don't have any further damage
to your any cells whatsoever. We had a question come in on the chat that says where could I find
IV right I would see available locally. Well you will have to search for that you'll have to do
a Google search for that. There's a lot of different IV centers that are popping up all over but
they're typically in higher population metro areas and they do use you can get IV vitamin C for them
they're typically just kind of marketed to not so much cancer patients
better they're really not marketed cancer patients at all they're marketed to people who are like
wanted to do an IV drip after you know a hard day out party or wanted to do a IV vitamin C drip
because they feel like they are they're a flu coming out or something like that so they're
marketed more to the executive situation so but there there are some some clinics and some
franchises that are popping up all over the place in the Twin Cities we have multiple that are new
in the last six months and you could you could Google search your area. Next question
I noticed my hair falling out I blame it on age at first but it's getting worse my hair stylist
believes it's becoming more serious seeing that after my hair is is shampooed I had a bunch of hair
in my comb so what causes hair loss so the most common cause of hair loss other than somebody
doing chemotherapy that damage the hair follicles if you lose your hair so let's say I'm not doing
chemotherapy why would I possibly have hair loss the first thing that you think of from a functional
medicine perspective is thyroid issues so that's the first thing you want to investigate
hypothyroid or high TPO antibodies where you have Hashimoto's which is an autoimmune thyroid
will cause hair loss and you will get a lot of hair loss so that's the first thing you want to
investigate how would you investigate it you need to get your T3 these are thyroid this is a
thyroid test so a complete thyroid workup would be taking T3 free T3 T4 free T4 reverse T3 TPO antibodies
in a TSH test so when you if you get that back if you can get that done locally if you have an issue
with hair falling out the other symptoms that you have with Hashimoto's or hypothyroidism would be
fatigue would be weight gain would be difficulty losing weight would be slow metabolism would be with
Hashimoto's you can have episodes of increased thyroid which could be racing heart irregular heartbeat
so there's a lot of different symptoms that can be involved with thyroid dysfunction
and getting a good thyroid panel can be beneficial we could take a look at that and see how
you want to treat that it can be tied to iodine deficiency as well but that does tie to thyroid
function so you can have more of a functional hypothyroidism so getting an iodine checked might be
valuable too there are some obviously other issues with hair loss and alopecia type hair loss where
you have an autoimmune attack to the hair follicles themselves that's a little bit different you would
lose hair elsewhere in your body too not just head hair but those are the that would be the most
common issue with hair loss the next question we had somebody said in some labs and
what would be abnormal about these labs right here so you look at red blood cell is low and
RDW that's red cell width is increased so very common with early ademia so ademia is a decrease in
red blood cells hemoglobin hematocrit and these red blood cell functions here this would be an
early ademia meaning that the only thing that's changed is the red blood cell and the red cell width
very common for the red cell width to increase so the red cells are actually enlarging themselves
in order to be able to help carry oxygen and iron so very common with early ademia so
what are causes of early ademia well there's multiple causes but if this person has just finished
chemotherapy that's probably your number one cause so and that was the case with this person so
as they clear out detoxify that chemotherapy I'm assuming this is very close to normal here but it
isn't the low end and so I'm assuming that this should recover just fine same thing with this these
are liver function tests your alkaline phosphatase and your aline amino transferase these are liver
function tests both of these are high now liver function tests are not indicative of any specific
disease but it does tell you that there's things going on in your liver but nothing specific so these
tests would be high if a person had metastasis to the liver but they'd also be high if you just
finish chemotherapy and you have a whole much toxins going through your liver so that would be
a pretty a normal reading post chemotherapy here so I'm not concerned with that these aren't
exorbitantly high anyhow but definitely definitely given this person just fitness chemotherapy this is
most likely a function of that and detoxify so this is where you go boy we really want to add make sure
we're doing coffee animals make sure we're doing casserole packs over the liver hot pan over the liver
so does everything that we can to help liver detoxification milk this will product supported
pond one pathways etc really important for this okay I am going to unmute everybody and open it up
for questions feel free to pipe it um this is Sharon um I've been hearing lately a lot about
doctors who take hair samples and then they provide different analysis like for one example would be
um my daughters friend they were able to do some analysis about what kinds of foods to stay away from
like which you know like similar to what you do but you you do a more thorough job and more scientific
but and then another one is like testing for heavy metals and kinds of things in your body
that may be taxifying are though is that legitimate okay I'll mute you and everybody and then I will answer
that okay here sample testing has been out on the market for decades um it has been improved upon
as far as the the test itself goes um but the problem that I it has problems too so the problem
that I have with herodelles is testing is that there's other things that affect the test so if you are
using you know everybody uses shampoo's and there's chemicals in shampoo's uh if you're a woman
and you're dyed your hair no obviously if you've seen me I dye my hair gray so that has chemicals in
it as well that that affects the test so there's things that can skew the test secondly it's a test that's
going to measure uh something in the past and it has been shown through multiple studies that that
heavy metals especially uh can come out in the hair follicles and can be expressed in hair samples
um but you're looking at where it was at several months ago right because it took months for that
hair to get there but there's there's there's just a lot of gray area with that so I personally have
never been a big fan of hair sample testing the uh the problem is is how else do you test for heavy
metals well first of all hair sample testing with for foods I think is um is not accurate at all
hair sample testing for heavy metals can be accurate but there there could be skewed data with that
so I've never been a big fan of it the problem is is that what what other way do you test for heavy
metals and the other test is what's called a provocation test where you actually give a person a high
dose key later higher than they'd be able to really pull out of the body and so you give them
EDTA or DMSA high dose the night before and then you do a 24 hour urine collection starting
in the morning and then you're looking for in the urine sample then you're looking for heavy metals
that have spilled into the urine because they were circulating in the blood because the key later
dropped them um that will give you a more accurate test of heavy metal toxicity the problem is
is you risk making the person sick doing that so you gave it gave them more key lady agent
than their liver can really handle you pull a whole bunch of heavy metals out of the tissues
and then because the liver can't handle getting rid of all that it spills into the blood and through
the kidneys and you urinate it out well that doesn't seem like a real smart idea if you really like
that patient so um I tend to like my patients so I don't do that test either so how do then you test
for heavy metals that's where you get down to um where kinesiology is the least invasive way to
test for heavy metals but one could even make the assumption that you definitely have heavy metals
everybody's got heavy metal toxicity so do we really need to test for it especially when
if you're going to treat it um your treatment basically get it's going to be indiscriminative
to whatever heavy metal you're to it's not going to discriminate against a specific heavy metal
so do I need to know that I have aluminum toxicity is the worst or do I need to know my mercury
toxicity is the worst what I'm going to use a product like a keelic clear that's going to pull out
all of it anyhow you know if I get to use a keelator a modified citrus pectin that will help pull out
heavy metals um it doesn't make any difference whether I am high in aluminum or I'm high in mercury
or I'm high in uranium it's not going to discriminate against which what it's going to pull all of them so
do I need to know that data it gets back to do a test if it's going to change the way you treat the
patient but some people need to have something hard written paperwork that that um gets them to take
the keelator to help detox some people don't some people can understand that you know I can assume
that um all of us have heavy metals while I have you muted and another question come in on the chat
it said avoiding beans due to histamine but read that beans sprouts are actually histamine scavengers
yes that's true so uh beans themselves are moderate in histamine moderate to high so if you're really
on a low histamine diet that's something that you're going to stay away from um maybe not all the time
but you're going to watch your consumption of that but beans sprouts don't have histamine in it it's just
it's very similar to to barley greens or uh even wheat greens uh wheat has has gluten has um
gluten in it right barley has gluten in it but the sprouts don't yet have gluten so you can have barley
sprouts and you can have um wheat sprouts but you can't eat wheat if you're staying away from gluten so
that's just the different things about food that are interesting so yes you could use
beans sprouts they are they can be histamine scavengers they can be good for you in a lot of ways so
beans sprouts are good choice of food and grow your own can be fun
okay okay I'm muted you so if anybody else has another question Dr. Carter this is
step sports from aile anyway I was watching your tumouric video um did you muscle test us if we
need tumouric or should we just order it and take some um I muscle test everybody so we do kinesiology
curcumin is one of the things that we test everybody for but if you didn't test for it could you
still make that and could it still be beneficial for you the answers yes so tumouric the active
ingredient of tumouric is curcumin and curcumin is anti-inflammatory anti-cancer it uh is good for
a lot of different things so yes that could be a good plus for everybody remember when you're
taking tumouric some people go oh there's going to go down to the local co-op and buy ground tumouric
and take that if you do that remember that you have you have to take it with a fat if you're just
taking ground tumouric you have to take it with a fat so you could cook with it and make fatty dishes
with it use coconut oil and it's better you'll increase the half-life of it if you also take it with
pepper with black pepper the the tumouric that we have is the tetrahedral curcuminoid which is
type of curcumin that you do not need a pepper with it to increase the half-life and it's already
pre-evil spied in a fat so our curcuclear has already got that in there at each capsule it's about
equivalent to a thousand milligrams of that so that makes it easier we have somebody with their hand up
I believe it's early yeah hi Dr. Connors hello hello yes oh hi Dr. Connors can you hear me
I did hear you you go ahead oh I have a couple of questions you know I've been there
approximately a month ago in your clinic and I'm using the right machine I'm doing everything I think
the coffee anymore everything and suddenly a couple of days ago I started to feel very very bad
and I just checked it out it's probably all of it for for the cleaning the body you know the
cleansing and I have a I have a terrible headache I'm trying to hydrate myself I don't know what
I has to do I'm making the lots of a lot of I raised my coffee I'm in from bond to every day
and I have ifra red sauna did also in that okay good and I just don't know how often I should do
that because you know I've started to sweat which I haven't did in ages I think never ever
sweat in my sweat in my whole life but I'm sweating and and I just wondering how often I should
make this sauna because I'm afraid I'm getting dehydrated I guess dehydrated anyway well we don't want
you to be dehydrated so make sure you're drinking water and if you're doing a sauna every day
you might want to add some minerals as well but I'm taking calcium and salt and I have four
we can see that humic acid you tested that for me it was very good for me according to the
kinisology yes so I'm taking that but yeah I just I just don't know I hope I'm doing that oh my other
question can I can I cut it off the time how long I'm taking so I have the program for example nine hours
but sometimes I've been okay so sometimes you're only getting 7 hours in it depends on how long you're
sleeping yes yeah that's fine that's fine okay okay good because because I felt and I put a little
bit farther from me the bulb because because I think it was too much for a while so I just I just
take it away I don't know maybe I have a meter or I have a feet okay yeah that's fine and I am
moody and and I hope I won't get depressed I would love to ask if you oh I didn't get my result of
of the thermo thermography yeah okay I'll have a head you retell to you then and I don't know about
the genetic test it's not that late am I right we didn't get that back yet okay and I just
wondering because I don't like to keep my computer on by fire you know I don't want any
mail or whatever get in on to it so I just trying not to have it on by fire how can I update or how
you really only need to update the frequencies every three to six months oh I see so I shouldn't
I don't suggest you keep it on Wi-Fi on a regular basis you don't need that going through that
machine yeah I don't I don't I have other computer to use so yes I okay thank you so I don't need
to worry about updating especially what you're using you're mainly just using the program that we
created for you even if you updated it doesn't change that program so you know the updated unless
you're using a lot of different programs and you're you're looking for the latest flu program or
something like that but yeah I wanted to use that once because I thought maybe I have the flu
but probably I would if you're not if you if you would do it everything and you haven't felt sick and
that you also do kind of feel really sick you might have a virus you might want to run a
strap program or a flu program or that viral complex program that's it to work real well you know
you could be coming down with something so okay oh and I read for example I should make a
liver guard blood flash which I don't know what's that well you don't necessarily need to do that
I did post the liver guard bladder flush on the Facebook page today because somebody else has to
about it okay and we could email it to you as well if you the okay I did check it on Facebook but thank
you thank you very much thank you very much so I think so far that's so that's all I always have
had million questions thank you very much I made a foreign just email about the therapy and
everyone the free day for you perfect thank you bye bye bye any other questions today no well thank you
very much I hope you guys have a good weekend and stay warm and do all your Christmas shopping and I
highly recommend that if you go to a movie the Grinch the new Grinch movie not this one which I'm
carrying but the new one that's out is a very kid friendly very cute little story so recommend that
as well all right you guys thank you very much I will side off bye bye bye bye thank you you have a birthday